so what's the latest on the protests in
France well they are still going on last
night about 150 people were arrested
during clashes in towns and cities
including Lil and Leon to lose but
really the focal point remains here in
non-terre the Paris suburb where 17 year
old nael was shot and killed and the
clashes last night were pretty
significant roads set on fire you can
see The Scorch Marks here just up this
street a Depot where eight Vans were
incinerated and look at these buildings
you can see the scars
one mother has told us that her son was
arrested last night she thinks the
police are being deliberately
provocative now the prosecutor has now
launched a formal investigation into the
police officer who shot nayel suspected
of voluntary homicide will that assuage
the anger there's not much sign of that
as we head towards potentially a third
night of clashes the tension is still
simmering